sept huit sociétés pour parler du
mariage homosexuel un sujet de société
qui fait débat parfois même au sein des
différentes formations politiques pour
en parler pour en débattre philippe
brillault bonsoir vous êtes conseiller
général des yvelines divers droite maire
du chesnay et également eddie aït
conseiller régional d'ile-de-france du
parti radical gauche maire de carrières
sous poissy petit rappel des faits une
loi est en préparation
elle devrait être présentée
prochainement l'avant projet a été
rendue publique les mariés auraient plus
de droits que les pacsés devenir parents
ce serait possible mais pas
l'insémination et la fécondation in
vitro pour débuter je vais vous donner
la parole philippe brillault vous faites
partie des opposants à cette idée de
mise en place d'un mariage homosexuel
vous avez même voté une motion en
conseil municipal alors déjà en quoi
consiste cette motion une petite
précision alors cette motion précise que
les élus du groupe majoritaire avec deux
autres qui sont associés dans
l'opposition ne souhaite pas que les
textes actuels du mariage hétérosexuel
soit remis en cause pour avoir le
mariage pour tous c'est ça la première
éléments de la motion la deuxième c'est
qu'on n'est pas content de pouvoir
réaliser un texte de loi pour le mariage
homosexuel ou l'union pour le mariage
sexuelle homosexuelle plus tôt en fait
on souhaite dissocier les deux et le
troisième élément c'est de pouvoir
assurer la protection des enfants est ce
que vous êtes fondamentalement contre
l'idée d'un mariage homosexuel pour être
très clair écoutez moi je sens que j'ai
fait à pied le mariage est dans son
principe et comme institution l'union
d'un homme et d'une femme c'est lionel
jospin qui le disaient en 2004 que cette
définition n'est pas dû au hasard et on
peut respecter la préférence amoureux de
chacun sans automatiquement
institutionnaliser les moeurs et c'est
ce que nous sommes en train de faire en
fait on est en train de créer la morale
des hommes et deux paires l'universalité
du naturel donc vous êtes contre en un
mot je suis content là ce qui est
présenté aujourd'hui je pense qu'on va
trop vite alors que le président nous
avait dit que l'on pourrait dialoguer et
si je suis là en face des dix à huit
c'est justement pour rechercher ce
dialogue
trouver la solution qu'il faut justement
et dialectes est ce que les choses vont
trop vite
non je ne pense pas bon d'abord moi je
suis pas un militant du mariage
homosexuel choix militants du droit au
mariage pour tous c'est à dire que je
considère que si la loi évolue elle
serait doit s'appliquer de façon
uniforme sur l'ensemble du territoire de
la république le débat va pas trop vite
il ya eu une campagne présidentielle et
législatives on ne peut pas dire que le
sujet a été absent des débats politiques
puisqu'il a fait l'objet de
contre-argumentation assez virulente
pendant la campagne l'espace du débat a
lieu les électeurs ont tranché et
l'engagement 31 du président de la
république aujourd'hui la majorité
parlementaire se met en mouvement pour
mettre en application cet engagement du
président moi je pense qu'il faut
revenir à la notion de droit
c'est-à-dire revenir à ce qui constitue
le socle de la république aujourd'hui il
est proposé une modification du code
civil et c'est ça qui doit être étudiée
et répartir les poser des questions
toute modification qui peut être
apportée à la famille au mariage a
toujours fait l'objet de très vifs
débats quand le droit au divorce a été
réinstaurée en 1884 les débats ont été
d'une violence et d'une passion qu'on
n'imagine même pas aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui il est légitime que des gens
expriment leur opposition monsieur brio
a fait le choix de le sceller par une
motion de son conseil municipal c'est
son droit ce qui est intolérable
aujourd'hui c'est que certains maires
puissent prétendre refusé de célébrer
des mariages une fois que cette loi sera
évolué et ça ça porte atteinte au devoir
qu'il eu l'idée déjà d'une motion par
exemple telle qu'elle a été votée est ce
que ça vous a choqué non mais ça les
majorités politiques peuvent se
prononcer ça me choque dans le sens où
je considère qu'il faut laisser le débat
parlementaire aller à son terme et qu'
il ne faut pas prendre en otage des
administrés au sein des villes par la
représentation de mer que nous sommes
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui nous n'avons
pas le droit de refuser de marier un
couple homosexuel si la question doit
être réglée après l'adoption de la loi
c'est l'article 75 du coaching des
grands avec des revenants vos âmes
interpelle quand j'entends ça ça veut
dire que
vingt pour cent des français ont voté
nicolas sarkozy et il n'a pas été
jusqu'au bout alors qu'il avait des
engagements c'est parce qu'il avait bien
compris qui avait quelques soucis et
qu'il fallait continuer à faire un
travail avec les personnes qui
revendiquaient cela est le deuxième
point c'est que parce que monsieur
hollande est élu on doit voter ce texte
mais je m'inscris en faux je m'inscris
en faux et je crois que cette refonte de
la société brutale on en voit les
conséquences et on va voir les
conséquences et quand vous dites il ya
très peu de maires qui se mobilisent
détrompez vous je pense que la masse
silencieuse va l'ouvrir et on va parler
parce que on va parler du vif du sujet
dans le vif du sujet de ce texte
derrière il ya comme tous les enfants
enfin quand on a un projet textes tels
que je les lui que le père et la mère
c'est les parents la femme et le mari ce
sont les époux ça veut dire qu'on est en
train de rayer le naturel qui existe
depuis des millions d'années qui vous
fait perdre pas le mariant de peur pour
employer ce terme aux uns et aux autres
à si vous préférez c'est pas le mariage
j'ai peur d'en modifier le texte oui
c'est pas le mariage en lui-même
homosexuel qui progresse aussi c'est
l'adoption possible derrière ces deux
choses de mélanger l'hétérosexualité et
l'homosexualité dans un texte législatif
et dans une cérémonie et deuxièmement de
pouvoir ouvrir la porte à des notions de
procréation d'enfants parce qu'on parle
de l'adoption mais l'adoption c'est un
épiphénomène
on est en train d'ouvrir une boîte de
pandore sur tout ce qui est phénomène
procréation deux femmes deux hommes
c'est pas la même chose qui vivent
ensemble mariage homosexuel ne sera pas
pareil pour les garçons et pour les
filles et puis qu'est-ce qu'on va faire
sur cette procréation sais quelle femme
qui va porter l'enfant on va les
chercher à spermatozoïdes on peut le
trouver en france un regret peut pas le
trou dans mon monsieur brio appartient
une famille politique il reprend les
arguments moi je les entends et je
souhaite moi rappeler deux choses
aujourd'hui ledroit différencie bien la
question du mariage et de la filiation
puisque depuis 72 maintenant on ne
reconnaît plus de différence entre un
enfant dit naturel ont un enfant
illégitime c'est à dire issu d'un
mariage et je tiens aussi à rappeler que
le droit ne reconnaît pas non plus de
lien entre filiation et procréer on
puisse que ça viendrait nier le droit à
l'adoption qui aujourd'hui une réalité
et signale que depuis 66e droit à
l'adoption il est ouvert aux personnes
seules femmes ou hommes donc aujourd'hui
il est une réalité le rapport à l'enfant
est une réalité pour un homme
célibataire ou 1 ou un couple marié
les nombre de familles monoparentales
explosive au divorce la condition de
l'enfant les déjà posé les textes qui
protègent les enfants existent je trouve
qu'il ya quelque chose qui n'est pas dit
et je crains de ce qui se cache derrière
cette peur pour l'enfant à travers un
droit au mariage reconnu pour tous et
c'est en cela que je condamne mois avec
force les propos d'un certain nombre de
représentants religieux qui ont dépassé
les limites de l'éthique et de la morale
et je crois qu'il faut recentrer le
débat aujourd'hui il ya une loi qui sera
proposée au vote le débat il aura lieu
avec majorité parlementaire qui sont là
pour exprimer leur opposition mais parce
qu une élection a tranché la question
sur le pacte majoritaire dans une
élection qui lui a prédit la langue
avec une plate forme dans laquelle
figurait la reprise de cet engagement à
30 jours le comprendre et je n'ai pas
pris le temps de lire les arguments des
adversaires socialistes radicaux de
gauche ou écologistes qui ont porté ce
là aujourd'hui c'est une réalité ça fait
partie des engagements le président or
son engagement et elle sera portée
devant l'assemblée qui délibérera
procédera des amendements le christian
et c'est une réalité réglementaire et
législatif se battre pour ce qu'on vit
aujourd'hui il ya une majorité
parlementaire c'est ainsi d'argent de
ces sociétés c'est à la population de
décider je crains cela il ya la
conception d'antennes conception forte
donc d'un souhait t on à référendum vous
ne souhaitez pas de référendum
nous avons tout de même posé la question
à quelques saint quentinois êtes vous
pour ou contre l'idée d'un référendum
c'est l'une de nos questions du jour
souhaitez vous un référendum sur cette
question du mariage homosexuel on vous
écoute
je pense que ça c'est une bonne chose
je pense que
c'est
je pense que c'est important de ces
changements de société important et je
pense qu'il émettrait
effectivement y'a un référendum c'est
vraiment amont afin quelque chose de
très très important et sa paume à mes
yeux une simple loi suffit qu ingénieur
c'est pas la peine d'aller au delà
aujourd'hui pour moi je pense que c'est
évident si les gens veulent se marier de
même sexe n'est pas de souci on fait une
loi on valide terminée oui pour quelle
raison parce que c'est quelque chose qui
va contre les valeurs habituelles de la
république et de la france tout
simplement et je crois qu'il est
important d'avoir l'avis de tous les
français non non olemps ii ça fait onze
ans que le mariage existe donc ya pas de
raison il faut que la société évolue et
c'est pas la peine de légiférer par
référendum pour non non non mêmes droits
pour tout le monde y compris pour donc
on sait que gay et lesbienne nous
poursuivrons donc ces débats cette
discussion autour du mariage homosexuel
faut-il ou non l'autorisé faut-il ou non
un référendum nous avons en ligne le
député de la 11e circonscription des
yvelines le socialiste jean philippe
mallet bonsoir bonsoir merci d'être en
ligne avec nous dites nous tout
simplement notre position déjà souhaité
vous ou non un référendum sur cette
question
le référendum il ya des parlementaires
qui sont là pour pour pour voter pour
voter la loi en revanche je souhaite
c'est ma position c'est ce que j'ai déjà
suggéré qu'il y ait des états généraux
qu'ils soient organisés pour pour que
les grands mouvements de pensée de la
société française les religions les
spirituels mais aussi des spécialistes
de la question de l'enfance qui dans les
colonnes des journaux ont des avis
différents voire contradictoires puisse
s'exprimer c'est une question importante
c'est une question anthropologique qu'il
peut pas se régler simplement à l'aune
des bas d'état parlementaire
avec les dérives que l'on pourrait que
l'on pourrait avoir des dérives ou les
le poids de simplement politique que que
qui est celui du débat parlementaire
question l'anthropologie que vous avez
des questions anthropologiques tout à
l'heure vous employer des mots très
forts vous avez demandé ces états
généraux vous j'ai rencontré cet après
midi claude bartolone le président de
l'assemblée nationale il a été réceptif
à cette idée simplement vous savez sur
un côté hull et que j'avais avec lui
quelques députés de l'île de france pour
pour travailler sur des dossiers qui
intéressent les franciliens est la
région de france j'ai simplement
une réunion informelle je vais suggérer
concernant le cette question du mariage
pour tous est ce que cette idée a eu un
écho favorable en tout cas bon vous avez
sont pas
prononcées ne s'est pas prononcé mais en
tous les cas les jo les jeux les
avancées dans ce déjeuner de travail
merci jean film est d'avoir été en ligne
avec nous pour ces quelques précisions
cette question anthropologique qui se
pose selon vous c'est le terme que vous
avez employé puis ces états généraux que
vous souhaiteriez voir se mettre en
place philippe brillault les idées de
d'état gérées revenir sur le témoignage
de mme aux collègues qui est également
conseiller général c'est qu'en fait au
début il dit je suis pour parce que je
suis socialiste
mais quelque part j'ai quand même pas
mal de réserves qui sont celles que
j'exprime donc je pense qu'on doit
pouvoir essayer de trouver une solution
on se donne quelques mois pour pour y
réfléchir et je crois qu'on peut trouver
une solution pour que deux personnes
homosexuelles puissent trouver une union
avec un texte législatif c'est tout à
fait faisable mais attention ne
transformons pas le mariage hétérosexuel
dans un mariage pour tous pourquoi pas
la limite marié aussi les polygames on
va y rentrer et c'est là justement vous
parlez du conseiller général jean
philippe mallet christine boutin qui est
aussi un conseillère générale elle qui a
déclaré c'était sur europe 1 il ya
quelques jours le 6 octobre elle à ce
sujet jugé vraisemblable que si on
accepte le mariage homosexuel l'on soit
amené dans les années à venir
accepter la polygamie en france eddie
aït je vous fait réagir
ce déferlement de sottises idiotie qui
qui se font le relais
d'autres personnes et c'est assez
scandaleux des élus puissent autoriser
un tel discours et j'invite vraiment à
retourner à l'école et à reprendre un
petit peu les fondamentaux de la
république maire du viiie arrondissement
de paris aussi quelques heures l'arrêt
d'aller dans son propre camp il
craignait des dérives pédophiles vous
avez jusque là bas non je peux pas
laisser dire bon je le peux je le
respecte en tant qu'élu local mais on a
le droit de respecter aussi les autres
et ne pas tenir des propos violents tels
que tel que tel que tel que tu viens de
le dire quand il faut faire un peu de
sémantique à l'heure mais c'est la
polygamie mais alors très attention à ce
qui est dit aujourd'hui attend à une
parole la société actuelle on n'a pas
attendu une et quelques élus
parlementaires qui sont retrouvés lui
grâce à un antisarkozysme est parce qu
hollande est élu je crois qu'on est en
train de les lancer à mulroney
parlementaire malheureusement donc je
vois gagner rires il ya un espoir de
l'être mais comme le changement
politique que tu as dit souhaiter au
chesnay je crains que malheureusement
soit plutôt niveau national qu'il arrive
vite si on continue comme ça je pense
que la masse silencieuse qui est une
majorité des français aussi bien à
droite à gauche aussi bien par les homos
ne sont pas d'accord sur la
transformation du texte actuel du
mariage hétérosexuel faut trouver une
autre solution sinon on va sortir dans
la rue et on fera non pas les pigeons
mais on fera les aigles qui iront à
paris pour faire rejeter cette loi et
vous verrez qu on se mobilisera et si la
loi passe si elle est votée c'est
acceptez-vous l'appliquerait non
personnellement je ferai jouer la clause
morale et je ne me marierai pas et vous
ne respectez pas les principes de la
république chez balland voilà j'ai pas
dit ça si nous avons pris une motion
c'est pour dire avant le texte de loi
que nous émettons les plus grandes
réserves en tant que médecin je n'étais
pas favorable à l'avortement on peut pas
obliger aujourd'hui avortement je
retiens un texte qui va obliger tous les
hôpitaux à voir aussi cette obligation
il faut arrêter la démocratie c'est
aussi de respecter les autres et je
demande à la volée nous révolter dans
chaque commune chaque maire adapte le
code civil adapte les lois un petit peu
à sa sauce ça va devenir un petit peu
compliqué sans doute hélas aux miséreux
marié shediac je pense qu'il faut une
paisible se marier à carrière je pense
qu'il faut être un peu sérieux si ce
n'est
sinon on est vu dans le cadre du débat
qui est le nôtre tout d'abord on parle
pas d'une loin mais d'une loi qui va
porter réforme du code civil intéresse
qui a fait l'objet de nombreuses
réformes je rappelle quand même que le
mariage et la famille ne sont pas des
institutions naturel mais des
institutions sociales et qu'il est très
régulièrement adapté ses cedex et jospin
ils pensent ce qu'ils veulent moi je
pense aujourd'hui ce qu'est la réalité
des faits présentés c'est vous pensé par
une majorité par les whites et les
propos des dirigeants mafieux briller
quand je termine mon argumentation
d'accord mais vous aurez tendre d'y
répondre en mélangeant un certain nombre
de genres ce que je veux dire ici c'est
que toutes les sociétés qui ont adopté
ces nouvelles dispositions le droit à
l'adoption le droit au mariage n'ont pas
terminé dans un déclin absolue comme
nous le promettent je ne sais quel
fanatiques religieux ou quels relais
d'opinion qui perdent la place qui est
la leur en confondant l'élu de la
république qui sont et le relais
d'opinion de différentes pensée
intégriste et je les invite vraiment à
se recadrer très rapidement sur le débat
et à ne pas oublier qu'un élu de la
république est là pour faire appliquer
la loi et que si monsieur le maire du
chesnay a le droit de pas donner mariage
il doit s'assurer qu'un adjoint par
délégation le fasse et il n'est pas
évident que cette clause morale soit
garanti là et je vous invite vraiment
être très prudent si vous invite
vraiment être très prudents et à 12 en
extraire et règles républicaines du
respect du code civil qui a été mis en
place par les révolutionnaires mais la
peau les os rendre à l'état nanan le
mariage premier acte d'état civil avec
le divorce et les autres ont été mis en
place par les révolutionner un hack pour
rappeler que c'est la république c'est
la fiq sexuelle code fond et qui choque
des fonctionnements et non parce que
vous avez les enfants de rentrer dans ce
débat que vous allez me philippe
brillault des débrayages référons ira je
ne dérape pas bref je vais juste vous
avez déjà dérapé je dirhams pomme
philippe brillault je vous interromps
eddie aït aussi on va juste prendre une
petite pause on va écouter justement ce
que pense quelques autres maires du
département des yvelines nous avons fait
le tour sur saint quentin en yvelines
pour recueillir leurs réactions vous le
verrez au sein même des conseils
municipaux je le disais en introduction
les avis sont partagés regarder
philippe brillault le maire
divers-droite duchesnay à semer le
trouble la semaine dernière en faisant
voter une motion par son conseil
municipal pour refusé en l'état le
projet de loi sur le mariage homosexuel
une question de société qui semble donc
faire débat et nous avons voulu savoir
quelle était la position des élus de
l'agglomération
il ya d'abord ceux qui sont ouvertement
pour elles ont même affiché en mairie de
guyancourt par exemple un pacs entre
deux femmes ya été célébré c'est tout à
fait juste légitime et c'est simplement
marquer que les homosexuels sont des
citoyens comme les autres n'oublions pas
que ça concerne 100 milles plus de cent
mille couples homosexuels en france et
que dans le monde onze pays l'ont déjà
adoptée ce mariage homosexuel et sur 4
continents
il faut donc s'adapter aux réalités une
réalité aussi pour les mères de la
verrière et magny les hameaux à partir
du moment où
dans notre société moderne
s'organisent les choix individuels donc
le choix de vivre ensemble quel que soit
le sexe et bien on peut aller
effectivement jusqu'à la reconnaissance
parce que ça donne des droits ce sont
des droits finalement c'est la
reconnaissance des droits ça fait partie
du programme du parti socialiste et donc
de françois hollande et de la majorité
gouvernementale
donc c'est une avancée de la société
vers l'égalité donc c'est le mariage
pour tous il n'y a aucun souci pour moi
attrape le maire socialiste affiche une
position plus nuancée pour lui la
question est complexe quant aux élus de
droite de l'agglomération ils sont
également mesurées et en tout cas il
souhaite établir un débat c'est un débat
que j'aurai avec mes élus mais encore
faut-il déjà que nous puissions avoir
des bases de réflexion puisque aucun
texte de loi à ce jour ont été votées et
en tout cas je n'ai pas vu celui qui est
en préparation
même si michèle losier à temps de
consulter son équipe municipale certains
au sein de celles-ci ont déjà pris
position c'est le cas du conseiller
municipal mathieu colombani proche de
christine boutin il souhaite un
référendum mathieu colombani a twitté en
tant que mathieu colombani aujourd'hui
en tant qu élu de montigny il n'a pas
encore participé débat quel qu'il soit
au sein de l'équipe municipale
la question du référendum un autre élu
s'interroge le maire de
voisins-le-bretonneux il estime que ce
débat n'arrive pas au bon moment ce sont
des questions en fait que je me pose en
temps en temps que maire
est ce le moment
de d'aborder ce sujet là alors qu'on est
dans une très grave crise on a dépassé
des trois millions de chômeurs alors la
deuxième question que je me pose c'est à
ton
consulter les maires
ce sont les maires de france et leurs
adjoints qui célèbre les mariages
les attend consulter le maire ump
d'elancourt jean michel fourgous estime
également qu'il y à d'autres problèmes à
régler en france et il reconnaît des
questionnements au sein de son équipe le
débat est donc loin d'être clos une loi
sur le mariage homosexuel devrait être
présenté en 2013
est ce que dans vos conseils municipaux
respectifs philippe brillault eddie aït
votre position fait l'unanimité est-ce
que vous en avez débattu aussi le
conseil municipal par exemple non mais
nous aujourd'hui on attend très
clairement que le projet de loi soit
présenté ma position en tant que maire
ali connu aller une position
officiellement présenté à travers les
médias auprès de mes élus aujourd'hui un
maire un adjoint et un conseiller
municipal délégation par arrêté spécial
marie par délégation parce que l'on nous
confère ce droit à marier donc les
maires sont informés et les
parlementaires consulter sur la réforme
du code civil mais on se doit
d'appliquer ce qui est la règle pour
tous de façon uniforme sur le territoire
municipal pour ça que moi je parle d'un
droit au mariage pour tous il ce n'est
pas une revendication communautaire est
ce qu'au sein de votre conseil municipal
tout le monde est d'accord avec votre
position il est cette motion qui a été
votée mais elle est adoptée limité sur
35 élus on a les deux membres de la
gauche qui sont favorables à ce projet
et les autres qui sont favorables à
trouver un projet de texte d'union pour
les homosexuels de conserver nos textes
sur le mariage hétérosexuel et surtout
de protéger l'enfant par
une législation qui soient renforcées
autour justement de ce mariage et de
l'autre côté de lui on va repartir dans
les rues de saint quentin en yvelines
avec cette question êtes vous pour être
vous contre le mariage homosexuel la
question est claire est ce que vos
réponses le sont aussi regardons ah oui
je suis pour pour parce que ça fait de
mal à personne et pourquoi pas enfin
pourquoi interdire ça
tout ça je trouve ça ridicule il faut
légiférer par rapport à ça parce qu'il
ya des situations qui sont un peu bancal
au niveau de l'avenir des enfants et
tout ça donc je suis pour enfin pour
dans la mesure où voilà ça peut rendre
heureux des gens pourquoi pas battus
pour
quelle raison parce que ils ont le droit
de manifester
leur amour et avoir envie d'avoir un
lien officiel donc non je suis pour
nous parlions ce soir du mariage
homosexuel avec eddie aït le maire de
carrières sous poissy également
conseiller régional et philippe
brillault le maire du chesnay également
conseiller général je vais vous laisser
un mot chacun pour pour conclure exposer
votre point de vue est peut-être appelé
les autres à rejoindre votre point de
vue on va commencer par vous fait librio
eddie aït terminera puisque vous avez
commencé en début d'émission merci moi
je suis d'accord avec ces dames on est
d'accord pour que les homosexuels trouve
une loi pour s'unir par contre nous
sommes défavorables je suis défavorable
et nous sommes nombreux à modifier les
textes aujourd'hui du mariage qui est
entre un homme et une femme pour avoir
des enfants et les protéger
aujourd'hui les familles homoparentales
existent plusieurs dizaines de milliers
d'enfants font l'objet d'une vie en
famille mono homo homoparentales donc je
considère que la république à cette
mission à garantir la diffusion uniforme
du droit et cette réforme elle est
essentielle pour garantir une
citoyenneté exemplaire parce que
derrière il ya une forme d'homophobie
l'attend et il faut être très prudent
sur ce qui peut être dit et j'invite
vraiment toutes et tous à la
responsabilité il n'y a pas de jugement
de valeur on a le droit d'être opposé
une évolution du modèle familial je
considère aussi que la république doit
assumer son rôle merci à vous d'être
venu sur ce plateau exposer vos
arguments je rappelle que le projet de
loi sur le mariage homosexuel doit être
présenté en conseil des ministres d'ici
la fin du mois ce débat sera aussi
retrouver sur notre site internet dès
demain matin et si vous nous avez suivi
en direct entre 18 et 19h sachez que
l'émission sera aussi diffusée aux
alentours de 19h45 également à 22h30 et
minuit le 7 8 sur téléphiles se poursuit
en ce 9 octobre à nous allons parler à
présent de la soirée de gala qui se
déroule en ce moment du côté du jeu
drôme de saint-quentin-en-yvelines nous
allons aussi parler de la cité de la
gastronomie que des élus locaux
aimeraient bien voir s'installer à
versailles
et avant d'évoquer le vélodrome quelques
mots sur le match de la coupe de france
de hand féminin qui oppose et montigny
le bretonneux à octeville-sur-mer
l'équipe yvelinoise évolue deux
divisions en dessous et à l'arrivée la
logique a été respectée anthony rech
pas de nouvel exploit après la victoire
face à aulnay pour les joueuses de
montigny en coupe de france devant
octeville-sur-mer pensionnaire de
division 2 lésigny motten envers n'ont
rien pu faire face aux grands gabarits
des arrières octevillaises malgré une
défense très dur et des montées de
balles rapides l'écart se creuse vite 17
à 9 à la pause pour octobre
offensivement il était difficile de
trouver les solutions défensivement
c'est c'est beaucoup plus d'efforts qu'à
l'accoutumée des gabarits sont
différents c'est en avait trois filles
qui ont été largement en tête c'est
difficile d'y faire face grâce à un
excellent début de seconde période les
joueuses de stéphane paysans font une
partie de leur retard et ne sont plus
menés que de cinq buts avant de louper
quelques opportunités de tir et de
craquer physiquement en fin de rencontre
34 19 à l'arrivée le score il peu
flatteur mais l'entraîneur est ni mon
teint reste fier de ses films j'essaie
de faire ce qu'on sait faire ça après
défendra cette dure mais monter les
ballons prise de risque alors ya
beaucoup de pertes de balle mais c'est
une seule autre jeu on aurait beaucoup
de prise de risque dans notre jeu 7 je
demande donc les filles ont fait ce
qu'il fallait faire voilà mon aucun
cependant n'a pas radicalement crédit
lésigny monteyne peuvent désormais se
concentrer uniquement sur le championnat
de nationale 2 à commencer par ce samedi
avec la réception du sambre avesnois en
mal